Antibiotic-resistant bacteria is already a
growing problem.
But is the food we eat making it worse?
Hello everyone, Amy with you on DNews today.
Every vegetarian has their own reason for
going meatless.
For me, meat’s just too chewy.
For others, the drugs farmers feed livestock
might be behind their rationale to go meatless,
and this one is actually something meat eaters
should know about.
According to the Food and Drug Administration,
antibiotic use by the meat industry is on
the rise.
The most recent FDA report said the amount
of antibiotics sold to farmers and ranchers
for administration to livestock has gone up
by 20 percent between 2009 and 2013.
Why is this a problem, you ask?
For the most part, human antibiotics are administered
to animals that aren’t sick.
Livestock destined for your grocery store
don’t exactly live in spa-like conditions.
These animals are often crammed together in
cages or pens that aren’t the cleanest,
which means they can get sick and might not
grow to a healthy size.
It would make sense that improved living conditions
would yield healthier, bigger animals, but
that costs money, and drugs are a cheaper
option.
Human antibiotics added to animals food and
water supply can help them grow as much as
3 percent larger than they normally would,
which is significant in an industry where
the product is sold by the pound.
And while this might be good for the farmers,
it’s pretty bad for the rest of us, particularly
those among us who eat meat.
Giving healthy animals antibiotics kills off
weaker bacteria and creates a perfect environment
for antibiotic-resistant bacteria to grow
and thrive.
Those bacteria travel to us, the consumers,
directly in the meat or indirectly on the
hands of workers who may be exposed to the
antibiotic-resistant-bacteria-rich meat.
If you eat undercooked meat where those antibiotic-resistant
bacteria are present, you could get sick with
a bacteria that an antibiotic can’t treat.
The CDC says around 2 million Americans get
infected with antibiotic resistant bacteria
every year.
And at least 23-thousand people die from those
infections.
According to Pew Charitable Trusts, the US
uses far more antibiotics in livestock than
other nations, Norway and Denmark use about
six times less antibiotics raising animals.
Feeding antibiotics to animals is illegal
in Canada and a number of European Union nations.
A federal policy was put in place last year
that would force drug manufacturers to label
their products as unfit for animal consumption
unless prescribed by a veterinarian.
But this policy didn’t address a major loophole.
Farmers can argue that they’re feeding their
livestock drugs to prevent illness, which
is an effect of the antibiotics in the animals’
food supply.
The meat industry doesn’t publicize figures
about drug usage in livestock so it’s hard
to say just how much antibiotics make it into
our food supply.
But according to a study published in the
Proceedings of the National Academy of Sciences,
more than 63-thousand tons of antibiotics
were used by livestock farmers in 2010.
Researchers expect that number to rise by
67% by 2030.
On the other hand, some companies are beginning
to cull or even eliminate the use of human
antibiotics on animals.
Recently McDonald’s announced it was phasing
out antibiotic-fed chickens in its U.S. restaurants.
Chipotle and Panera have been offering antibiotic-free
meat for a while now.
But in the mean time, it’s still legal practice
in the United States.
If you wanna know more about antibiotic resistance
and the search for a cure, check out this
episode of Seeker Stories that follows a team
of researchers to the bottom of the ocean
to find the next antibiotic.
"You say this is a crisis, if you had to rate
it on a scale of 1-10, where are we at on
the antibiotic crisis?"
"Eleven.
It's very serious.
We are about to return to a pre antibiotic
era where even basic surgeries and other basic
procedures could lead to death by bacterial
pathogens."
And if you’re on mobile, we’ve got a link
to that video down below.
So what do you guys think.
Are you worried about antibiotics in your
meat?
Let us know in the comments below or you can
find me and let me know directly on Twitter
as @astVintageSpace.
And don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.